- [Announcer] Thanks to curiosity stream
for keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
(crowd shouting)
- I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say when 100s
of Ku Klux Klan members
show up to your trial,
its probably a good
idea to grant the motion
for change of venue.
(soft upbeat music)
hey Legal Eagles, its time
to think like a lawyer.
Welcome back and welcome to my new set
which fun fact, its actually not a new set
its just against a
different wall in my office
but now, with 100% more lamps.
So welcome, today we are
covering A Time to Kill,
the classic legal thriller
starring Matthew McConaughey
and Samuel L. Jackson.
I've actually never
seen this movie before,
despite lots of people
recommending it to me.
I think I was a little
young when this came out
so its going to be a
treat for me to watch this
as I'm expecting a lot
of courtroom theatrics
and a bunch of constitutional questions
based on the description of the movie.
As always, be sure to comment in the form
of an objection, which
I will either sustain
or overrule, and stick around
until the end of the video
where I give A Time to Kill
a grade for legal realism.
So without further ado, let's dig in
to A Time to Kill.
(soft tense music)
- Hey, who's that?
- She looks a little young.
Hold this.
- Okay, I'm going to
refrain from showing you
the graphic images in this
particular part of the movie
but I think its going to set
up the rest of the narrative.
It looks like those two Southern boys
have sexually assaulted the daughter
of Samuel L. Jackson
and then attempted to kill her.
So I think that that
sets up the legal premise
of the show
but for the sake of being safe for work,
I'm going to refrain from
showing you those images
but just know that that happens
and is important for the story.
- How many appointments
do we have today, Ethel?
- Not a one.
But it is the first of the month
so (mumbles).
- Well the checks are pouring in,
we have enough money to
pay all our past debts
and then some.
- That will be your last drink.
- Just keep us no more
than one month behind
on any vendor, please.
- You have been drinking.
- Two months.
- Well these are the most delinquent.
The rents in there.
- I appreciate the practice, capitan,
I do but you could of left
me a couple of clients.
- This is actually really interesting
because the economics of
being a solo practitioner
is something that you
don't really see a lot
in movies.
Here you can see Matthew
McConaughey is struggling
to meet his bills and to pay his vendors.
Which is obviously very
important when you're running
your own business.
But when you are the only
attorney in your law firm,
you live and die by
not only having clients
but having clients that pay.
So its actually very common
for solo practitioners
to get behind on their bills
because not only do the clients
ebb and flow but also the clients
ability to pay changes over time.
That's why a lot of law firms of this size
and even bigger law firms
will get what's called
a line of credit, which
is a revolving loan
that allows them to meet their debts
in lean times and then pay it off
when the clients come back.
Because obviously you don't want to have
to shut your doors just because
the clients have dried up
for a small amount of time
and Matthew McConaughey
in this particular scene
is dealing with the economics
of being a small practitioner.
(laughing)
- Billy Ray Carb, you and Mr. Willard
need to come with me.
- Hell no, I aint moving.
- You know that little
girl you took for a ride?
- What little girl?
- I got bad news for you, Billy Ray,
she didn't die.
So unless there's another red neck asshole
got a souped up yellow pick up
with a confederate flag in the windshield.
- Hey, blue gums!
Why don't you take your
coal black ass out of here
and grab a branch?
- Unless you've got an
explanation for what this
was doing in the bed of your
truck, you're going to jail.
Now get up.
- So this is obviously very dramatic
and probably important for the story.
When the police have probable cause
to arrest an individual who is suspected
in a capital offense, a felony like this,
there's no reason to engage
in any kind of pleasantries
or engage in any conversation.
They're going to arrest these two guys
so there's no point in
having a conversation
with them.
The proper procedure here would of been
to avoid the conversation,
go straight to arresting them,
assuming that they have a verified ID
of these two guys
and then give them a Miranda warning
so that whatever they
say can be used against
them at trial.
Right now, since the police officer
has not administered a Miranda warning,
the statements of these individuals
can't be used against them
and won't be admissible in court.
So there's really no point
in taking out your anger
against these guys.
Just follow proper procedure,
give them a Miranda warning, arrest them,
and then get their confessions.
- You go to hell, (bleep).
(shouting)
- Now you earned the
right to remain silent.
- I mean he always had the
You know the police can get
in really big trouble here
because the kind of force that they used
was completely unnecessary.
It was sure provoked by the
statement of the individual
but the police just can't use this kind
of overwhelming force just because
they don't like what this person has said,
especially when they
haven't given this person
a Miranda warning.
So it can be very satisfying, I'm sure,
to beat the crap out of these guys
who are clearly very very bad people
but that's why we have
rules that apply to everyone
regardless of how you personally think
about these defendants.
That's the point of our judicial system.
So the police really
should have administered
the Miranda warning.
They should not have let
this situation escalate
because that's not in anyone's interest
and you can get a fourth
amendment violation
when you use this kind
of force unnecessarily.
Not good police procedure.
- What can you tell us, sir?
- Can you tell us what happened?
- Will you give us a statement, Sheriff?
- Are you in the police department?
- No, I am a lawyer.
- Are you Carl Lee Hailey's attorney?
Sir, are you Mr. Hailey's attorney?
- Yes, I am.
- I mean it should of been
up to Samuel L. Jackson
to determine if Matthew
McConaughey is his attorney or not.
You can't just walk
outside and decide that
he's the attorney.
- Alright, first things first.
Brigance will file for a change of venue.
- He'd be a fool if he didn't.
- Why's that?
- Why?
Should we tell our young,
uniformed law clerk
the reality of just
prudence in this county?
Evelyn, give me the state
file on race statistics.
- Oh boy.
- See, Taylor, its quite simple.
This county's 26, 30% black, give or take.
Almost every other county is 40, 45,
in some cases, 70% black.
Blacks are more sympathetic
to other blacks.
If he gets it moved,
he has a greater chance
of coloring the jury box
and we know what that means
but if the trial stays here,
its an all white jury for sure.
Now Taylor, this is for you.
To integrate your brain with
before three o'clock tomorrow afternoon.
- Yes.
- He means without blacks on the jury,
Hailey hasn't got a chance in hell.
- Okay, so some of that makes sense
some of that is constitutionally infirm.
In this particular case, a change of venue
is probably warranted because
this particular community
is going to have lots and lots of opinions
and potentially a lot of prejudice
about this particular case
because its going to be in the news,
its going to be a hot topic.
Now one racial issue that
this prosecutor has mentioned
that is a big problem
is he says that this community
is 30% African american
but he's going to get an all white jury.
A jury is supposed to be
an accurate reflection
of the community
and if you start picking a
jury that does not reflect
the community in that way,
you're likely to run into
a constitutional challenge.
That may be what this prosector wants
but that's not the way the
systems is supposed to work
and it may present an appealable issue
even if he were able to secure
a guilty verdict at trial.
The appeals court might
overturn on the grounds
that its constitutionally problematic.
- Alright, Noose is up for reelect.
- Yeah, November.
- Good.
Reach out to our friends
in the legislature.
Have them call on Judge Noose.
We're just gonna help him decide
to keep this case in Canton.
Also.
- Oh my god.
- Send a case of whatever it
is he's drinking these days
to Lucien Wilbanks.
- I believe that's (mumbles).
- I want to keep that old
drunk on the sidelines.
- Yeah, Becky, get me Sam.
- Okay, that is definitely
prosecutorial misconduct.
There is no way that
the prosecutor can call
friends of the judge and ask those friends
to influence the judge in a sitting case.
That is completely improper.
That is basically bordering on bribery
to ask the judges friends to intervene
with the judge, engage in
ex party communications
with the judge, to influence his decision
on a pending capital murder case.
That is definitely something
that the court of appeal
would look at if evidence
ever came out about that.
I think the court of appeal
would overturn this decision
like that
and on top of that, I
think that the prosecutor
would be in real trouble
with the ethics committee
of the state bar.
I think that this exactly
what the ethics rules
are in intended to prevent.
And luckily this kind of thing
doesn't happen very often
in real life.
It does, unfortunately, happen
but the prosector should know better,
that's completely improper.
That should never happen.
- [Reporter] What do you
think of Mr. Brigance?
- Isn't that boy still in law school?
Say hey to your husband for me.
That's all.
(crowd shouting)
- Alright.
So there's the courtroom.
So this particular courtroom looks like
they basically just reused the set
from To Kill a Mockingbird,
which is to say that is
not a realistic court room.
There are courtrooms that
exist that look like this
but for the most part, they're used solely
for ceremonial purposes.
They are not used for
active capital murder cases.
This actually would be not a
particularly good courtroom
to try a case.
Its huge.
You know, you got a
lot of distance between
all the different witnesses and the judge.
Its actually just difficult to be heard in
a courtroom like this.
Its really impractical
for trying an actual case.
- Now, Noose selects this panel at random.
We get too many bad candidates
upfront, we're sunk.
- Luck of the draw.
- What you need is young fathers
who want to do what Carl Lee Hailey did.
- Agreed.
I think we need young
men with families here.
Now I would prefer no one over 50.
Less bigotry as a rule with youth.
- So we stay away from
women, rednecks, and old men.
- So they are planning
what's called voir dire,
which is the system by which you choose
the members of the jury that
will form the jury at trial.
You have a large panel.
Many of you have probably
served on jury duty,
so you've seen this process in action.
You start with a large panel
and then you whittle that
down for various reasons.
You are allowed to have what
are called peremptory strikes,
which gives you the
ability to strike a juror
for any reason whatsoever
and you're also given
strikes that allow you
to remove a member of the jury
or a potential member
of the jury for a cause.
You demonstrate to the judge
that they are so prejudicial
that they cannot issue
a fair verdict.
Often, the judge will
use his or her discretion
to remove those people from
the jury panel themselves
and neither the prosecutor nor
the criminal defense attorney
have to use a strike to
get rid of that person.
But with peremptory
strikes, you are allowed,
technically, to remove people
for any reason whatsoever.
There are limits to that power
but practically speaking,
that's what you do to try and get a jury
that is favorable to your side
as opposed to the other side.
Of course, both the prosection and defense
are both using the same tools,
the peremptory strikes to try
and get the jury that they want.
- Citizens, thank you.
The council each have 12
challenges let's begin.
- 12 challenges would
be peremptory strikes.
- Your honor, the state
challenges jurors number six, 10.
- Oh geeze.
Okay what the movie is hinting at here
is that the prosector,
played by Kevin Spacey,
is striking all of the African
Americans from the jury.
You're not allowed to do that.
Now its true, theoretically speaking,
that you can use a peremptory challenge
to get rid of anyone that you want.
However, there are
constitutional limits to that.
In 1986, the US supreme court,
in the case of Batson V. Kentucky,
held that a prosecutor
cannot use his or her
peremptory strikes to
strike all of the members
of one race from a jury
without stating a valid reason for each
of the individual members who
were struck from that jury.
That's exactly what Kevin
Spacey is doing here.
He said so earlier in the movie
that he was going to do that
and here he's trying to strike
all of the African
Americans from the jury.
That is constitutionally infirm
under the sixth amendment
under the Batson v. Kentucky case
and I think that's a slam dunk on appeal.
- I've totally reviewed your brief request
on change of venue
and I agree with you,
I think its impossible to
find a fair and impartial jury
here in Canton.
In fact, I think its
impossible to find a fair
and impartial jury
anywhere in Mississippi,
and as such, a jury here would be as fair
as a jury anywhere else.
- Oh boy.
- I've decided to deny your request
for a change of venue.
- I think the judge
here is probably wrong.
Doesn't seem like he's really
considered the evidence
or the situation at bar.
The city is at a boiling point.
There are Ku Klux Klan
members protesting every day.
That seems really really prejudicial
and there are probably parts of the state
where you can move this case
and get a more impartial jury
that hasn't heard as much as
everyone in this community has
so on top of the entire
conversation being improper,
I think the decision
that the judge has made
is wrong, whether that
rises to what's called
an abuse of discretion,
which is generally the standard on appeal
when appeals court is reviewing
the lower courts decision.
I don't know but the
judge is just wrong here
and given the impropriety,
its probably going to be overturned.
(crowd shouting)
I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say when 100's
of Ku Klux Klan members
show up to your trial,
its probably a good
idea to grant the motion
for change of venue.
- Sheriff, if you would,
would you please identify this weapon?
- The weapon found at the scene.
- Were you able to identify
any of the fingerprints
found on this gun?
- Yes, the prints on the gun matched those
of Carl Lee Hailey.
- You're sure?
- Yes.
- Your honor, I'd like to
enter this into evidence
as exhibit S18.
We have no further use of this witness.
- A couple of problems of
what just happened here
talking about the murder weapon
in this criminal proceeding.
Number one, again this
testimony may not be relevant
because I'm not sure it
goes to the state of mind
of the defendant.
Number two, if you were
handling a physical object
where fingerprints where important,
it would be wrapped in plastic
in a sealed plastic bag.
You wouldn't be handling
it yourself in court.
Also, you would probably
not want to bring an M16
into the actual courtroom with
a magazine attached to it.
You can just use pictures and
enter those into evidence.
On top of that, what the
prosecutor really should
be doing here is not just
identifying that this weapon
was used to kill the two victims
but what is relevant to state of mind
is the fact that Samuel L.
Jackson had to get that weapon
out of his gun safe and he
had to load the magazine
and he had to put the
magazine into the gun.
He had to then sneak into
the courthouse, hide,
all of these things show premeditation
and cognizance of what's going on
to counteract the defense of insanity.
That is what this prosector
should be showing.
That the defendant knew what he was doing
and isn't legally insane.
Its not just that he used
a gun to kill people.
That actually supports
the defendants side.
What he needs to do is negate that
and talk about his state of mind
or at least show the
things that demonstrate
the state of mind of the defendant.
He's not doing that and as a result,
he is not preventing
the defense from using
their insanity plea.
- Did you arrest Billy
Ray Cobb and Pete Willard?
- Yes, I did.
I arrested them for the
rape and attempted murder
of 10 year old Tonya Hailey.
- Is it true that Pete Willard
signed a written confession
saying that he and Billy Ray
Cobb did rape Tonya Hailey?
- Objection your honor,
that's inadmissible
and Mr. Brigance knows it.
- Mr. Brigance, I've spoken to you before.
We are not trying the
rape of Ms. Hailey today
but the murder of two young men
and if you continue in this performance
I'll hold you in contempt.
- Okay, the prosector was way way late
in objecting if that is inadmissible
then he should of objected to the fact
that the policemen arrested
the two men before.
Its not just the confession
but all of the evidence of bad acts
that would be inadmissible.
But as I pointed out before,
number one I think it is admissible
because it goes to the state
of mind of the defendant.
What he thought those people did
and again, ironically, its the prosection
that would want that information in.
It shows that the defendant
acted in a premeditated way
because of the sexual
assault of his daughter.
So I am skeptical that number one,
that information is inadmissible
and number two, its the prosecution
that would want that in in this courtroom.
So some weird perverse arguing here.
- My name is Dr. Wilbert Rodeheaver
the chair of psychiatry of
Mississippi state University
and clinical director of
the Whitfield facility
for the criminally insane.
- Thank you doctor, your
credentials speak for themselves.
- No they don't.
Okay when you are trying
to use expert testimony
on the stand it is very
very important to bolster
that witness credibility.
Often you will spend
half an hour, 45 minutes,
an hour just going over the credentials
of your witness, to demonstrate
that your witness is entirely credible
and that their opinion is based on science
and experience.
In the federal court
systems you go through
what's called the Daubert Standard
for ensuring that your witness
meets the standard for admissible evidence
and being able to opine
because regular witness, lay witnesses,
are not allowed to offer their opinion.
They are only allowed to talk about
what they actually saw themselves
and what's within their
own personal experience.
Experts, on the other hand,
are allowed to offer their opinion.
That is what they are there to do
is to give their scientific opinion
based on the evidence
that you put before them.
So it is incredibly important
to make sure that not only you demonstrate
the foundation that your
witness, your expert witness,
knows what they're talking about
but that their credentials
really are impeccable
and simply stating that
your expert psychologist
is in fact a psychologist
is not gonna get it done.
Number one, that doesn't demonstrate
to the judge that their opinion is valid
and number two, it doesn't show
to the jury that they
should trust this person
and as this movie has pointed out,
credibility of an expert
opinion is very very important.
- Now, doctor, can you please explain,
as you do so eloquently in your book,
the M'Naughten rule for the jury?
- Certainly, the M'Naughten rule states
that a person must be unable
to tell right from wrong
and or be unaware of the
consequences of his actions
to be termed legally insane.
- Okay that is actually a
reasonably good statement
about what the M'Naughten rule is.
Now a couple problems with that.
Number one, that's a legal standard
so its not really up to
the expert psychologist
to opine as to the ultimate issue
about whether the defendant
meets the legal standard
for legal insanity.
That's for the lawyers to
do based on the witnesses
testimony about their opinion
about the mental state.
The bigger problem is that no one has used
the M'Naughten rule in 60 years.
The M'Naghten rule actually is based on
English common law in the 1850s
where someone attempted to kill
the British prime minister,
well M'Naughten tried to kill
the British prime minister.
He missed and killed the
prime minister's secretary.
A man named Peale, I believe.
Now based on the circumstances,
I think it was the court of Exchequer
said that M'Naughten was legally insane
and could not be found guilty as a result.
He was then put in a insane
asylum for the rest of his life.
Most US courts replaced the
M'Naughten rule in the 1950s
with what's called the Durham rule
and at least regarding
federal courts in the 1980s,
the Durham rule was
replaced with a definition
of insanity laid out in the
Comprehensive Crime Control Act
of 1984.
So the M'Naughten rule hasn't been used
in a very very long time.
In most jurisdictions now,
the defense has to prove insanity by clear
and convincing evidence
which is a very high standard.
Its not quite as high as
beyond a reasonable doubt
but its still a very high burden.
To demonstrate that the
defendant at the time
of the alleged wrongdoing
did not understand
the nature or quality
of his or her actions
and did not understand the
wrongfulness of the act.
So its a much higher
standard than that laid
out in M'Naughten.
- Doctor, who do you work for?
- State of Mississippi.
- In your 11 years of
working for the state,
how many times have
you testified in trials
where the insanity defense was used?
- This is my 46th trial.
- 46th trial.
Well of those 46 trials, how many times
did you testify that the
defendant was legally insane?
- Objection, your honor,
the good doctor cannot be asked
to recall all of his testimony
at these previous trials.
Its absurd.
- Overruled.
- Yeah, that's a really bad objection.
One of the most common questions
you will get as an expert witness
is how many times you've testified,
how many times you've
testified for one side
versus you've testified on the other
because people know that there are experts
that are going to testify
on behalf of the defendants
or largely on behalf of the prosecution.
Often, a good witness will
intentionally have cases
where they have testified on either side,
purposefully to avoid seeming biased
in this kind of context
where you have only testified for one side
instead of the other.
- I can't remember.
- Could it be, doctor, that
the reason you can't remember
is that in 11 years and 46 trials
you never have seen a defendant
whom you have found insane.
- I can't recall at this time.
- That's another way to
screw up your testimony
is to say that you know definitively
that you've testified 46 times
but you can't remember
how many times you voted
on the other side.
That's opening yourself
up cross examination
and destroying your credibility
as an expert witness.
You don't do stupid things like that.
- You never have seen a defendant
whom you have found insane.
- I can't recall at this time.
- Can you recall testifying
at the trail of one Dan Baker?
- Objection, your honor, this has nothing
to do with the proceedings here.
- Overruled, this better
be good, Mr. Brigance.
- Thank you, your honor.
- This better be good is
not a reason to overrule
someone's objection.
The prosecutor should
have stated his grounds
for objecting and gotten a response
from Matthew McCognaughey
but yeah there is no legal
standard that evidence
can come in if its going to be good.
Doesn't work that way.
- In 1985, you testified that
Dan Baker was legally sane.
The jury disagreed with you and Mr. Baker
was found not guilty
by reason of insanity.
Since that time, he has been
a patient in your hospital
under your care as a
paranoid schizophrenic.
Is that correct, doctor?
- Yeah.
- Do you normally admit
patients, keep and treat them
for 10 years if they are
of sound mind and body?
- Of course not.
- Then it would be fair to say
that you find insane people
sane for the purposes of trial.
- Objective your honor,
this is argumentative.
- Yeah, so that is argumentative
but the points that he was
making were perfectly valid
points and as a good way to show the bias
of a particular expert in this case.
Matthew McConaughey has done a good job
of impeaching this witness credibility
by showing that he testified
previously that a man
was legally sane but
then admitted that person
to his mental institution
as an insane person
and has kept him there for over 10 years
on the basis that he's insane
and that actually raises
a really interesting part
of the insanity defense.
Most people get really
upset when they think about
a murderer being found not
guilty by reason of insanity
thinking that they just go free.
They don't.
When you find someone legally insane,
they go to a mental institution.
They do not go into the public
and its true that there is no set time
that they have to be kept
in that mental institution
but that really cuts both ways.
Its true that they can
be let out immediately
upon finding that they are legally sane
but what happens most of the time
is those people are kept in that place
for the rest of their lives
and in fact, M'Naughten who gave the name
to the M'Naughten rule
after he was found not
guilty by reason of insanity
spent the rest of his life
in a mental institution.
So don't think that just because someone
is found not guilty by reason of insanity
it means that they're going scot free
into the public at large,
on the contrary, they might spend
more time in a mental
institution then they would
if they were found guilty
of the underlining crime.
- Mr. Hailey.
Before you stepped outside of yourself
to watch yourself shoot
Mr. Willard and Mr. Cobb,
were you aware that if
convicted they might be freed
in only 10 years?
- Yes, I heard people say that, yes.
- Okay, goes to his mental state.
- No.
- Do you think two men who rape a child
should be free in 10 years?
- Its starting to get argumentative.
- Hang a child.
- Object.
- Should be free in 10 years?
- Well what do you think
should happen to them,
what would be a fair sentence?
- Object.
- Do you think they
deserved to die, Mr. Hailey.
- Your honor.
- Now, Mr. Buckley.
- Carl, don't answer that question.
- They deserved to die?
- Yes they deserved to die
and I hope they burn in hell!
- Yeah, so this is such an obvious trope
in legal dramas.
The prosecutor doesn't get to do that.
You don't get to slowly
approach the witness
as your asking more
argumentative questions
after argumentative question.
Number one, you don't get
to enter the well like that
without permission of the judge.
The bailiff will tackle you.
On top of that, you don't
get to raise your voice
and yell at the defendant
and get this Perry Mason
moment where the defendant
basically admits that
he wanted to pre
meditatively kill someone.
Like, that's, that's not
how these things work.
The defendant has a 5th amendment right
not to take the stand
and there is nothing in that
testimony that he just said
that helped his case and in fact,
I think legally speaking, he showed
that he had the mental
state required for murder
and not the mental state required
for the insanity defense.
So that's a classic
reason why you don't put
a criminal defendant up on the stand.
There's just no reason for it.
- Soaked in her blood.
Left to die.
Can you see her?
I want you to picture
a little girl.
Now imagine she's white.
- Okay that is a very
eloquent closing argument.
The problem is that in closing arguments
you are not allowed to
put improper emphasis
on the victim's race.
Historically it has been the prosecution
who has put too much emphasis on the race
of the victim in order
to drum up high emotions
against the defendant
but I think the same rule
applies to the defense.
The system is supposed to be colorblind
and the race of the victim here
is not strictly relevant
as to whether or not
the defendant in this particularity case
is more likely or not to
have committed the crime
that he's accused of.
So I think that that's
probably an improper closing
argument to make
and it is likely to be an issue on appeal.
(upbeat music)
Okay now it is time to
give A Time to Kill a grade
for legal realism.
(gavel pounding)
This was a heavier movie than we are used
to dealing with on this series
but I think its important
to address these dramas
because these kind of issues do show up
in real life courtrooms from time to time
and I would be remiss not
to talk about these subjects
and I think this movie does a good job
of talking about some issues
that you don't really see.
The economics of being
a solo practitioner,
the issues of race that show up constantly
in our judicial system,
regardless of our efforts
to try and stamp those outs
and even some technical things like
the M'Naughten rule,
while its not the right standard,
it was the right standard
at a certain point in time
and they did deal with
some of the nuance there.
Unfortunately, the movie dealt
a lot with over dramatizations
they left out a lot of
the proceedings that would
normally occur and often oddly
the prosecution was
arguing 100% the wrong way.
They were arguing for
things that would help
the defense and the
defense was arguing things
that would help the prosecution.
So all in all, I give A
Time to Kill a B minus.
It is definitely a
worthwhile drama to watch
but some of the nuance is plainly lost.
A Time to Kill shows us what happens
to our institutions when
they are at a breaking point.
I'm currently enjoying a documentary
on how that kind of stress
effects the presidency
on Curiosity Stream.
Its called Presidents in Crisis.
Its a great piece about
how presidents Lincoln,
Roosevelt, and Johnson
were all transformed
by personal trauma and how that affected
the way that they governed.
If you're looking for
the best documentaries
and nonfiction movies out there,
you should definitely
check out curiosity stream.
Legal Eagle's get a
free account for 31 days
by clicking on the link below
or using the promo code legal eagle.
So click on the link below,
check out the greatest documentaries
on the planet and until next time,
I'll see you in court.